after the joint decision by the brewers
and the reds not to play
last night's game as a moment to reflect
on the racial injustice and systemic
oppression happening in our society
right now in light of the events in
kenosha on sunday night we are back at
miller park today for baseball and we're
going to play a doubleheader the first
one ever here at miller park
for the brewers 27 years of age adrian
hauser the righty on the mound we're
going to see a lot of strikes he's not
afraid to get the ball within the strike
zone
digging in shoko akiyama standing in to
get this one started
on the ground it goes gobbled up by
orlando garcia and tim when
adrian house was right you can see a lot
of ground balls like that one up and one
down here in the opening inning
nick reds right fielder and castellanos
lines it into right field for a base hit
it's a one out base hit and the first
base runner of the game winker in there
for the first time today at 299
as winker goes the other way and this
one will fall
so back-to-back base hits off of hauser
here in inning number one
and now eugenio suarez will come to the
plate bouncer hit to third they'll go to
second for one the relay
yes for the double play
to end hauser's opening inning on the
bound for the reds the ace
of the staff that's right he's sonny
gray he has been just
outstanding this year and he's ready to
go to work against alva syl garcia
on the ground and right at jose garcia
making his major league debut and
cleanly makes his first play
went away and now christian yelach will
be the hitter and elijah lifts a fly
ball
toward left coming in it's mark payton
to make the catch
and that's out number two and kesten
hira coming up fastball strike three
called right on the outside corner well
thrown by
gray hero strikes out and the brewers
are down one two three in the first and
now the first
major league at bat for jose garcia
he has not played a game above high a
and it's on the ground going to be a
tough play
and it's the first major league hit for
jose
garcia in his first major league at bat
congratulations jose garcia
the first of many to come in the box
score it's a screaming line drive
and you don't care how you got it you
just know you got a hit
in the major leagues because sally will
stand in two on
with two out as casalli finds a hole and
galvez will score
and the reds have a one-nothing lead
back to the top of the order now and
shoko akiyama
akiyama takes low runner off for third
and not in time
and jose garcia has his first major
league
stolen base and it's a steal of third
now they're at the corners
with two out with the runner going
there's a ground ball over to sogard
and up the line is akiyama but the throw
is in time
they're out number three
peterson will be the batter swinging a
bouncer back
up the middle in the right center nope
it's gloved by
garcia with a diving stab and he saved a
run there
so the rookie shortstop his major league
debut here today
he just saved a run he's got a stolen
base he's got an infield hit
but the bases are loaded now and the
batter is eric sogar
breaking ball hitting the air to right
castiano's over he's got it he'll make
the running catch in the right center
field alley and the brewers leave them
loaded
nick castiano some base hit back in the
first inning
will be the first man to face adrian
hauser in the air
center field this will drive back garcia
that bad boy is
gone i mean way way out of here nick
castellanos a big boy swing mercy
and the reds now have a two-nothing lead
and now jesse winker he has had the best
success against adrian hauser of anybody
in this reds lineup
winker going the other way opposite
field power
how about back to back jacks red spats
coming to life here in the early going
three nothing reds castiano's
jesse winker coming up against alex
claudio giving up runs in each of his
last two appearances
winker opposite field again did he
did he he did jesse winker
second home run of the game this time a
two run
job and the reds are in business
it's now five nothing cincinnati sunny
gray has been
the sunny gray we've grown used to four
innings of shutout baseball
so far given up four hits he has struck
out four
fly ball high into the air shallow right
center
and on to get it is castellanos and the
inning is over
five scoreless in the books for the
right-hander sonny gray the reds have
runners in the corners now with one out
nick castillano's coming up now
castellanos another drive but this one
the ballpark will
hold but this will bring in a run as
tagging up and scoring
is jose garcia six nothing reds two men
are out
and that'll bring up omar narvaez here's
a swing and a
fly ball to right get up get out of here
and gone
for omar norvaez home run number two of
the series for omar narvaez and against
the brewers on the board
that's got to be careful now there's
runners at first and second with two out
and ryan braun as i mentioned had a bat
he will now head out to pinch it
breaking ball strike three called ron
doesn't like it a bit but biddle will
take it
works around trouble last chance for the
brewers here in this seventh inning tilt
brewers down to their final out the
matter is justin smoke
got him and the reds take game one of
the doubleheader
6-1 is your final as they play long ball